VICE PRESIDENT PENCE SAYS OF
NORTH KOREA WANTS TO TALK, THE
U.S. WILL TALK WITH THE PRESSURE
ON THE REGIME STAYS ON.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
♫ ♫
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I’M BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IT’S TIME
TO REBUILD AMERICA AFTER
SPENDING TRILLIONS IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN.
THE PRESIDENT IS ROLLING OUT A
MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
PERMITTING REFORM PACKAGE.
HE CALLS FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY
TO PAY MOST OF THE $1.5 TRILLION
BILL.
THIS PART OF THE PRESIDENT’S NEW
BUDGET.
SEEKING HUGE SPENDING INCREASES
WITHOUT A PRETEXT TO BALANCE THE
BOOKS.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS START US OFF
TONIGHT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
FOR DECADES, SUCCESS OF
AMERICANS PRESIDENTS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT REBUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
OTHER THAN A FEW ROADS AND
BRIDGES HERE AND THERE, THERE
HAS BEEN NO COORDINATED PLAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HOPES TO CHANGE
THAT.
THERE ARE COMPLAINTS ABOUT A
MEAGER FEDERAL INVESTMENT.
WITH THE GOVERNORS OF SEVERAL
STATES AND LOCAL OFFICIALS IN
ATTENDANCE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNVEILED HIS PLANS TO
REINVIGORATE AMERICA’S AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> AS OF A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, WE
HAVE SPENT $7 TRILLION IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
$7 TRILLION.
WHAT A MISTAKE.
WE ARE TRYING TO BUILD ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND FIXED BRIDGES THAT
ARE FALLING DOWN.
WE HAVE A HARD TIME GETTING THE
MONEY.
IT’S CRAZY.
>> THE PLAN CALLS FOR 1.5 TO
$1.7 TRILLION IN INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT.
THE FEDERAL SHARE WILL BE ABOUT
13%.
$200 BILLION IN SEED MONEY FOR
GRANTS AND LOANS.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL INVEST
$50 BILLION IN RURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT.
BRINGING BROADBAND TO FARMS
ACROSS THE NATION.
>> RETURNS POWER TO STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO KNOW BEST
WITH THEIR PEOPLE NEED.
WASHINGTON WILL NO LONGER BE A
ROADBLOCK TO PROGRESS.
WASHINGTON WILL NOT BE YOUR
PARTNER.
WE’LL BE YOUR PARTNER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PLANNED TO
CUT FEDERAL RED TAPE FOR
PERMITTING.
HE WARNED STATES THEY NEED TO
STEP UP TO THE PLATE AS WELL.
>> WE GIVE YOU MONEY AND YOU
CAN’T GET YOUR APPROVALS, I
GUESS WE WILL HAVE TO TAKE THAT
MONEY BACK AND YOU CAN’T GET A
PERMIT.
IN ONE STATE IT TOOK 17 YEARS TO
GET A PERMIT.
>> WHITE HOUSE SHORT ON DETAILS
ABOUT WHEN OFFICIALS BECAME
AWARE OF THE ALLEGATIONS OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE LEVELED AT FORMER
STAFF SECRETARY ROB PORTER.
>> LOOK, WE LEARNED OF THE
EXTENT OF THE SITUATION
INVOLVING ROB PORTER LAST
TUESDAY EVENING AND WITHIN
24 HOURS, HIS RESIGNATION HAS
BEEN ACCEPTED AND ANNOUNCED.
>> THE FBI HAS KNOWN ABOUT THE
ALLEGATIONS AND PHOTOS SINCE
JANUARY 25 OF LAST YEAR.
THEY KNEW THEY COULD DISQUALIFY
PORTER FROM HOLDING A FULL
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
THE WHITE HOUSE SUGGESTED THE
FBI NEVER PASSED ALONG THE
INFORMATION.
>> IT IS HANDLED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITIES.
WE SUPPORT THE PROCESS.
IT’S THE SAME PROCESS THAT’S
BEEN USED FOR DECADES FOR
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.